I heard you're in a movie you just shot
a film yeah what are you in it's called
Halloween night Halloween yeah what do
you play I am a character was they
escaped from an insane asylum was in the
movie well it was me Richard and Salo oh
god are you kidding we're out in Vegas
for a couple days like the Rat Pack
playing poker was I times a I know I got
three kids we go to the casino after we
shoot this this great movie no and it's
at Caesars and it's like a there's like
a 45-minute way to get to a poker table
I bet your people who all his money go
then I go Pete do you want to play in
Pete's like yeah yeah yeah so I put down
my name Sal and you put goes bond Pete
so they put it down and about a half
hour later they go Sal Pete your tables
ready over to the table the food on the
table it was a dollar fifty three
dollars right I sit down Pete sits down
the guy says to me how many chips would
you like I said give me $100 and chips
and then he turns to Pete and he owes
Pete how many chips would you like in
Pecos
I'm just here to watch the whole table
every player just slowly turns their
head and looks at him feel like you're
here to watch it yeah I just want to
watch everything he's involved in people
just look at who puts their name down
for a half hour you probably are not an
experienced player
nor does he have any money he's been
waiting for a half hour he puts his name
down I mean at a watch he has nothing to
do all there nothing you have nothing to
do you have no responsibilities right
Richard you were in this film - yeah the
way we found out Pete was so unprepared
is they're literally getting ready to
film him yeah and I go Pete your scene
is great because I read the script and
goes oh it is
[Laughter]